[Music]
church bells on a Frosty Christmas
morning except this isn't December 25th
the official Christmas now recognized by
the KE government is January
7th the Christmas traditionally
celebrated by the Ukrainian Orthodox
Church according to the Julian
[Music]
calendar we are Orthodox in Ukraine we
celebrate today and will continue to do
it I think those who celebrate Christmas
on the 25th as my grandmother used to
say everyone goes crazy in their own
way inside they carry out prayers in the
Russian language the church has been
accused of having ties to Moscow
something they deny any ties were
officially cut following the Russian
invasion in February
2022 but for these ukrainians it isn't
about any perceived support for
[Music]
Russia the president made a sound like
all ukrainians are celebrating Christmas
in December we too are ukrainians and we
too celebrate Christmas it is not the
business of a secular state to comment
on which calendar religious communi
should live by how religious communities
live is protected by the
[Music]
Constitution but ukrainians are divided
not just by Christmas but by
territory in Russian control donet they
are also celebrating the festival but
not under the KE
government
tonight is a wonderful Christmas evening
despite all the difficult events in our
hometown we are in our hearts with faith
with faith in Russia with faith in our
Victory be happy and healthy be
strong despite when or where Christmas
is celebrated the rituals are the same
the prayers are the same it's just the
politics that
differ president zalinsky wants to show
European Western powers that his country
is aligned with them politically
ideologically and now even religiously
but for many people here religion is
separate from the state and they're not
willing to change their Traditions Assad
bag Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer